الليلة، مقطع فيديو جديد من الأمام تم تصويره
من قبل لواء الهجوم الأوكراني الثالث
يظهر جنودًا أوكرانيين يقاتلون من
الخنادق وفي هذا ترى
تبادل إطلاق نار مكثف. جنود النار الروس
يطلقون النار ولكن بعد ذلك
يتركون مواقعهم
ويتراجعون عن كل هذا تحت الهجوم.  إن النظر إلى
الأمر يأتي في الوقت الذي وصل فيه وزير الخارجية الأمريكي
أنتوني بلينكن إلى كييف
للإعلان عن تمويل أمريكي جديد يزيد عن مليار دولار
لأوكرانيا، ورد
الكرملين بهذا التحذير بأنهم
سيستمرون في
إبقاء أوكرانيا في حالة حرب و
لشن هذه الحرب ومواصلتها حتى
آخر أوكراني دون توفير أي أموال
لها،
آخر أوكراني فريد بليكن في المقدمة
لحظة ضرب الصاروخ القوي
سوقًا في كونستانتينيكا في شرق
أوكرانيا، فوضى ومذبحة في
أعقاب ذلك مباشرة، بينما
لم تعلق روسيا  في الغارة،
قال الأوكرانيون إن هذا كان من عمل
صاروخ أرض جو روسي استخدم
لضرب أهداف أرضية، مما أسفر عن
مقتل وجرح العشرات هنا، كما
تقول كييف، إن المستجيبين الأوائل يحاولون مساعدة
الجرحى بينما يقومون بالفعل بإزالة
جثث القتلى، أوكراني غاضب
الرئيس ينتقد القيادة الروسية
كلما كانت هناك أي خطوة هجومية إيجابية
من قبل قوات الدفاع الأوكرانية،
يستهدف الروس المدنيين والبنية
التحتية المدنية، ويقول إنه أينما
يمكن أن تصل صواريخهم ومدافعهم،
هذا ما يعنيه زيلينسكي بالخطوات الإيجابية،
يضغط الجيش الأوكراني على
الروس على الجبهة الشرقية هذا
الفيديو  تقول كييف إنها تظهر القتال عند
بزوغ الفجر بالقرب من باكموت وفي
الجنوب حيث تقول أوكرانيا إن قواتها
تدفع الروس إلى الخلف بعد الاستيلاء على
الروبوت في قرية وتحصين
مواقعهم،
ويتذكر جندي قاتل في الروبوتنا أنه كان يختبئ في القرية وحدها
من الروس على استعداد لقتل نفسه
إذا عثروا عليه،
كنت أحمل خرطوشة في جيبي،
ويقول إنني لا أعرف إذا كان بإمكاني فعل ذلك ولكني
حملت الخرطوشة، ولن
أستسلم للقبض عليها
في زيارة إلى كييف وزير الخارجية
أنتوني  بلينكن يشيد بالتقدم الذي حققته أوكرانيا
مؤخرًا في ساحة المعركة، فنحن
نرى التقدم المهم،
لكن بوسكو يقول إن قواته تلحق
خسائر فادحة بالقوات الأوكرانية المتقدمة،
وعلى الرغم من خسارة الأراضي،
يزعم الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين أن هجوم كييف يفشل،
وهذا ليس خطأ، ويقول إنه
فشل.  على الأقل اليوم، هذا هو ما
يبدو عليه الأمر، دعونا نرى ما سيحدث بعد ذلك،
وآمل أن يستمر الأمر كذلك، حتى
تقول القيادة الأوكرانية إنها
ستقاتل من أجل كل شبر من أراضيها
وتتعهد بالانتقام للمدنيين الذين قتلوا
في حادث آخر أسفر عن إصابات جماعية
بالقرب من أوكرانيا.  جبهة القتال من Pleiken CNN
Berlin